I play tennis with my friends I'm not
very good but this helps me learn how to
play better and at the same time I have
a Q&A with them so we even get to know
each other better too and today I have
[Music]
I'm so happy I have fusee today because
one you told me you're a really good
player really good so just as much as I
want to elevate people's spirits minds
and hearts I'm gonna elevate your tennis
game I need that and I also do have a
lot of questions for you well save it
for the game I just want to talk about
real quick before we start playing cuz I
know people are gonna comment about it
huh your outfit yeah like let's check it
I mean I think it's very freeing
it's very down-to-earth it's very uh you
know I'm glad you asked because people
are gonna think like oh he forgot his
tennis shoes yeah no no no these are my
tennis shoes
I like being in touch with the ground so
like when I get the energy to destroy
you want my serves you know my backhands
well if that works I'll start playing
barefoot for no I won't all right here
we go heads or tails heads heads it is
your serve all right here we go love all
and that's the lessons look at that was
like Flintstone feet running around
first question do you love keemstar what
almost out of the park but that's the
point for me baby
it's crazy are you crazy
huh are you crazy what you talking about
what was the first question back to that
oh do I love keemstar I do why me and
him like fixed our bond and everything
so I love him
and through this whole July 15th
experience don't hate the player hate
the game so you guys have like a
conversation already and you're planning
it like I don't have a phone anymore so
see me text for me he texted her to ask
how my mom was doing cuz she got sick
because of all the stress oh really
that was very kind of him oh yeah
horrible friend
had no idea about that Akeem started
yeah but he's like drama
oh stop distracting me that's the next
damn question I love keemstar so next
question are you crazy
we're all crazy I'm just brave enough to
admit it but I'm crazy from God God gave
me abilities God gave me disorders in my
head but it's all blessings I'm happy
I'm healthy I love God so I'm good did
you do the UM the meet up as a son at
what did you do it as a publicity stunt
hell no I did it to change the world in
what way I wanted to get all like-minded
individuals in one room to show kids
that like I'm not divided by LeBron
James because he's a celebrity with
talents and money he's at that show as a
human to tell kids screw racism screw
this screw that you know it's a bigger
picture I don't need a publicity stunt
did you think it was a success the
biggest success in my life which is why
it's tattooed on me now it was the first
day of the rest of my life and was it
because the turnout or more that it was
just a really good learning experience
it was everything I needed to know
so I got a tattoo that says now cuz it
taught me don't put pressure on days
like July 15th to get something done
trust in God have faith work hard in
silence and don't put pressure on
something I snuck into the club to meet
Drake I should have just trusted that
one day eventually through my good being
a good person I'm gonna meet him through
my intention I like that you're saying
that because I a thousand percent
believe and putting good energy out
there that's what it taught me the most
because everything that happened July
15th was done from the energy that I had
in my heart so I was walking with good
intentions
I met Drake in two hours I he forced it
a little too much too much which is why
it exploded which is why God told me now
live in the now which is why I'm now
barefoot enjoying a tennis match with
Amanda Cerny loving life I got nowhere
else to be right now but here
yo trials in life things that happen
obstacles they're not to stop you there
forgot to teach you a lesson of what to
do the next time it's bout your best
friend no I just like around with a
question I messed up do you have a next
date plan yes I do what is it not gonna
say cuz I'm working in silence like semi
we'll post a tweet post on Instagram but
all my work is now done behind the
scenes when I have all the artists sign
when I have the venue when it's ready
I'll say yo away I have an exact set day
and exact venue an exact time already
huh it's okay if it changes 100% I like
it but what I'm doing now I'm not
announcing it I'm not tweeting celebrity
saying I need you all about I'm not
tweeting celebrities saying I need you
my team who I have now is in charge of
getting the celebrities my goal is to
just meditate love life and let it
happen okay so are you doing like a
concert um it's gonna be
free concert run one baby you're serving
now fuzzy you just taking in all that
energy to win you're gonna need it so
what's up with I don't know if I should
ask this it's very personal but I'd like
to know as a friend of both of you
yeah what's up with you and Layla now uh
I haven't talked that's like you know oh
no see as I go with the deeper questions
my skills get better
I'm just warmin know for me it's like
I'm over it I forgive her for what she
did love it love even though she never
genuinely apologized like I hope she
grew from that experience too and that
she was able to become a better person
from it there are a lot of people in
life who have wronged me right yeah that
doesn't mean I now and they're friends
and hang out with them yeah
hey rice you want to settle this on the
tennis courts let's go bro you can't see
me I'm the Bowser of these cords yo
Amanda but the audience doesn't know
that like you know me in real life yeah
that's a joke yeah they take it as
serious really watch trust me I'm not
even gonna go near your comment section
I don't need that in my life no more Oh
Shi this like I'm not gonna lie uh when
I saw your like I watched all your
videos yeah and I was concerned of
course as you should be because you're a
good person and a friend and you're not
worried about the event whether Drake's
gonna be there or anything you're just
worried about is Yousef okay right now
yeah I wasn't like hate watching me like
oh look at like Oh No why didn't I go
for so check this out
my mom went to the hospital because
she's watching the live stream it goes
black next thing she sees I'm on top of
and
Varane news channel screaming yeah next
thing she sees philip defranco and
keemstar are saying Yusuf's gone crazy
she believed that I flew to New Jersey
to show her my eyes and be like I'm good
that's what I did do wrong though like
we said I had too much energy I had
excitement I looked at your eyes in the
video and they looked crazy to me they
did yeah I know that myself and I agree
with that now
Tyler Perry told me when I was talking
to him about getting on Ellen he said
for now take a break regroup
go take your mom on a vacation meditate
pray to God come back
then do it yeah so now I'm calm look at
my eyes now you tell me tell the world
my boy
I saw I saw you in person seeing you now
no but like your videos yes my event
gets canceled I'm on top of an uber with
no boys screaming exactly God put me in
an unfortunate circumstance but it
taught me a great lesson did you um end
up paying the uber driver
yup sixty-eight thousand dollars to buy
the car signed him to salary yesterday
so he's now my uber driver for life
really yeah he's gonna be in all my
videos that's all and that's the thing
yeah people on the internet making
speculations serve it oh my god besides
he didn't pay the uber driver he got him
fired
though the driver is now homeless living
with his family on the streets where the
hell y'all get that from
shut your asses up go enjoy your pop
tart love life Amanda yeah how does it
feel to get you ass beat by me in tennis
I wouldn't know Amanda yeah am I better
looking when I'm muscular and big or
right now loving myself loving well I
don't go to the gym no more hey I
thought Drake might have been a little
bit scared thinking you're a little bit
stalker a showing up Drake
our story isn't finished baby yeah you
you got to get him with you
you know I know and I'm saving that but
you know that night since you're friends
with batch
I walk up to obj okay Odell Beckham jr.
batches friend yep I handed my phone
he's the only crew they're left with
Drake's crew and he supported me in it
just so easy oh wow you're actually good
though love not as good as me but you're
good yo Amanda yeah who was better in
tennis me or rice gum well so far you're
beating me and I won against rice oh
[ __ ] come on you know you should do what
should I do
you should have invited me and rice at
the same time and not told us see that
would be very manipulative but the thing
is people think I don't like you that
were beefing that's my brother for life
are you guys meeting no yes yes because
he doesn't understand where I'm coming
from
I'm coming from a place with love so you
guys are just in an argument you don't
hate not even an argument okay we just
there's stuff we need to sit down and
talk about that's important it's like
when you're little like my older like my
older brother my older brother I never
connected with growing up yeah now after
July 15th we're having real
conversations as men what would be
something that you could tell me right
now that nobody else knows yet about
what just your plans are you know I
already have the new venue I already
have the new date the next event is
already ready yeah they don't know where
they don't know when they don't know how
they think I'm having a mental breakdown
right now and deserves to be in a mental
asylum
question on that have you um to confirm
that you're not going crazy and I know
you have friends and family around you
to say that you're not and agree with
you but have you spoken to a
professional that I now go to a
spiritual healer every other day and a
therapist two times
week awesome I got you girl protecting
myself
good Howie Mandel Howie Mandel told me
on the phone when I asked him for advice
he said whether your life's going good
or bad it's always nice to have somebody
to talk to for sure
so that's why I go to a therapist twice
a week I go to a spiritual hero every
other day I actually just came from my
spiritual healing session she said
there's so many cords this is the final
game it's the site it's what we learned
right you got to be calm in life and let
good things come to you obviously work
you might think I'm going crazy right
now I just have to take a big [ __ ] huh i
harness that energy I saved it for later
I'm a humble you real quick let's go um
July 15th that went exactly as I wanted
it to even if I didn't know it at the
time you serve even if I didn't know it
at the time everything's working out
perfectly God's timing is working
beautifully in New Jersey when you were
there though like what were you doing
hanging out with my mom okay
wait in the last year or recently the
whole year that you were there oh I was
playing fortnight and just smoking weed
on stream did you feel productive
nothing productive I just gave up so my
soul can recharge and find his purpose I
found my purpose through July 15 oh I
found my purpose through July 15 I found
the rest of my life I'm now not scared
to say my name is yousef saw a lot of
God I'm gonna be a motivational speaker
a spiritual teacher I study from osho I
study from Eckhart Tolle I study from
Rhonda Byrne I study from Napoleon Hill
I believe in the power up now I'm gonna
practice for the rest of my life
learning how to teach people the
skillsets that I'm learning is there
anybody that you're not friends with
nope
I love everybody in life
I can't even mean Batali had major major
major beef where if he saw me he
probably would have wanted to kill me
I invited him to the event oh really
yeah
why do you in Vitaly have beef I didn't
even know that I'm not like Edwards the
devil got in the way and chose us to be
enemies
it happens in life we were young here we
go you have to remind yourself some oh
man discerning how does it feel man
Estonia how does it feel to be humbled
by be great tennis Lord you know you
have me off balance in that last round
but oh I'll give it to you you won you
just go like this
no no not dad's be like this it's in the
wrist focus my young grasshopper alright
but before we're done yeah you know what
you showed me the beautiful thing about
what you're doing and why I want it to
be a part of this you got to allow me to
be myself on the tennis course I'm not
gonna go home to my girlfriend and be
like baby do you want to take tennis
loss classes together yeah cuz this is
the hobby I used to love as a child that
I gave up Oh 100% you gotta take back
your youth should this reminded me I had
so much fun right now like I actually
I'm sad that it ended yeah I was having
fun so thank you for that I just want
you to know as a friend if ever you have
advice for me if ever you see me and
even if you don't know shooting a text
just let me know yo Fuji I don't care
about who's there Drake Obama Trump
whatever are you good yeah don't ever be
scared to send help because we as people
need to help each other instead of the
youtubers who are so quick to make a
video talking about listen to this
they're making videos fouseytube is
crazy getting millions of views putting
millions of dollars in their pockets
instead of doing that why not reach out
to me and be like bro can I talk to you
in private you did an open therapy
session you're doing it
with me imagine this is what other
youtubers are doing imagine you set up a
tennis game just so you can talk about
with another youtuber about how I'm
crazy you didn't even invite me and I go
and I watch that but I am crazy and I am
suicidal what did you just do for my
mental health YouTube is a gift and it
can be used as a powerful one if we use
it to support each other and stop the
[ __ ] of putting each other's down
when I did project butterfly why I
agreed to do this right away when I did
project butterfly my intention was to
change the world I just didn't know how
to do it so I gave away my belonging
because I went outside I failed in 30
days people don't look at that intention
they just see he gave up in 30 days but
during that project butterfly you
invited me into your home when I asked
you gave me a facial you let me sleep on
the couch and you gave me love and
compassion more people need to be like
Amanda Cerny I just want to thank you so
much for doing this no like seriously
thank you I'm happy to see you like
smiling and not crazy eyed and loving
life I'm more grounded than ever you're
the you're the foodie I knew that stayed
at my house I want to end it with this
okay this is one I'm because I want you
to have my final statement in this yeah
all my years on YouTube I was miserable
but everyone thought I was happy because
I acted happy because that's what they
wanted me to be now for the first time
in my life I'm more happy than ever and
they all think I'm crazy
just think on let them think on that
yeah that's all that matters happiness
right you heard it here that was a fun
game Fuji beat me like subscribe turn on
the notifications I really need to like
get a coach or something love you guys
ow
[Laughter]
[Music]